時々体も体ものすごい軽いんだと
本当に軽いんだと 体重はないんだと
と感じるんですね だから人の欲と怒りがあればあるほど体が重いんです
歩くときに 例えばもう怠け者だったら
階段見たら あー嫌だ 階段だと思っちゃうでしょうね
そこでよっこらせと言って登らなくちゃいけない
それで膝が痛いし 腰が痛い
いろいろ だけど子供だったら何でも階段出てもどんどんどんどん上がって行くでしょうし
だからそれ観察してみると
自分の心でも気持ちが元気な時は階段は何のこともない
ちょっと疲れて元気じゃない時は嫌だ
エスカレーターないかという風に探したりはする
同じ人でも心変わるたびに歩けるか
ないかという ですから心が弱いんだったら体が硬くて重い
心は明るく 明るくて落ち着いているならば
体も軽くて柔軟性を持つようになります
そうするとさらに元気が出てきて頑張れたくなります
それで必然的に ひいては次にその体と心の軽さが生まれてきます
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想というのは決して苦行ではないんです
大変厳しいですよということでもないんです
で 経験としては楽な経験なんです
だから落ち着いているんです
そういう風に落ち着かないと
一切は苦であるということは体験できないんです
で 我々はね ライオンとかね
虎とかね 結構でっかい動物たちで大きい動物たち
猛獣たちだからね 見たいという気持ちはあるんです
それでアフリカのサバンナに行って
虎がそっちのけになってるかどうかわかりませんけど
行ってこうやって見たりするんですかね
遠く遠くなんか中に入って
やっと望遠鏡でなんとかで見て
あるいはバイノキュラーですか
そういうもので双眼鏡で見たりとかするでしょうし
そこで虎が檻の中に入って
きつくもう出られないような状態にいるならば
そばにいて平気でいろいろ牙はどうですか
尻尾はどうですかとかね
手はどうですか 足はどうですか
模様はどうです いくらでも見られるんですね
自分がすごい安定した状態にいるんだから
この恐ろしい猛獣を観察できるんです
で 自分が精神的に安定していないと
ヴィパッサナーでいい加減でやって現象が見えたりすると
その人は狂うかもしれません
全ては空であるとお釈迦様おっしゃってるんだから
それは事実なんです 全ては空であることはもうしか体験ないんです
事実だからしょうがないんですよ
自分も安定していない
これ見られない 逃げる
怖くなる だから無我のことを教えると
ほとんど愚か者が頭が混乱して狂っちゃいますよと言ってるんです
理解するところから頭狂ってしまっちゃいます
無我だよと言ったら 実体はないんだと
空っぽだと シューニャだから空だと言ったら
ですから この瞑想によって人がすごく落ち着いている状態がどんどん出てくる
これは瞑想の一部だけ
主観的なものだけ今説明してますけど
客観的なところはここで書いてないんです
客観的にその人が何を見ているかっていうことを書いてないでしょ
で 初めのサティの場合は
まあふくらみ 地味に左足
右足とかね そういう風に観察している
それからいくらかいくらか分別能力生まれてきたと
そこまで私は説明しましたけど
ここら辺で何を観察するか
何を観察するか 何を観察するかということは
私ども一応避けておくんです
そこはアビダンマ出てきましたね
最後の方で で とにかく修行者が主観的なすごい安定した状態が作る
安定した状態にいるんだから
怖いものない状態で物事を観察することができるんですね
ですから 両方ともちゃんと物の無常を見ることと同時に
心が落ち着いていることも必要なんです
発作的に落ち着いているよりは
すごく軽くなるということ
次にある言葉何でしたっけ？サマーディ
それでサマーディという状態が生まれてきますね
心も体も軽くなって 喜びもあるし
心も体も軽いし 柔軟性がある
それで 7番目に 6番目にはサマーディが生まれてくる
で ヴィパッサナーだから
この強烈なこのサマーディというよりは
この本当にこのサマーディ
あの まあそれほど強烈ではないんだけど
それなりのサマーディでは生まれてきます
サマーディっていうのは一つのものを観察できるような状態
妄想やらいろんな余計なことをしながら
たくさんものを同時に観察するとかあるでしょうに
それで時々 私は言葉はめんどくさくて
なぜならば同時にいろんなことを感じるんだと
膨らみ縮みだけじゃなくて
座ってることもあちこちも感じられるんだから
言葉でラベリングできませんと
だから私は言葉でやりたくないとか文句言ったりはしますけどね
それはあまり気にしない
それでも言葉で確認しないで行っちゃったら
それは正しい指導なんですけど
私は何もわからないんだと
本人が言葉なしに確認できるのに
できるなのに私は認めてないと
なんかひかっと変わった目で私の方を見るんですね
で でもそれはまあ そういうことじゃなくて
いっぺんにいろんなものが見えているということは
サマーディがないということ
サマーディっていうのはいっぺんに一つしか見えない状態なんですね
ヴィパッサナーの場合はこれ瞬間なんですね
ただ 膨らみということを見た瞬間に
他のことは全部消えてしまう
でもそこでまた他のものを感じるかもしれません
縮みという前に ただし
縮みということを感じると
また他のものが消えてしまう可能性もあります
それは瞬間瞬間つらつらと生まれるもので
痛みを見ていると痛みだけ見える時もあるし
それで体が消えちゃうんですね
感じてないんだから 膨らみ縮みだけを見ていられると体が消えていっちゃうんです
本人が消えたと感じちゃうわけですね
なぜ消えたかっていうことは
この膨らみ縮みだけを見ているんだから
他の方を見てないんだと
音なんかは聞いて もう何もどこにも行ってないと
そういうふうにこの一つだけ見ていること
見えることはサマーディなんです
この一つだけ見えることは覚るには必然的な条件
一つ別々にして見ないと無常は見えないんですね
ですから サマーディはどうしても必要なんです
サマーディ で 七番目はウペッカ
で サマーディは  定ですね
定覚支 一境性とか統一性ですね
それで一つだけちゃんと見えてきたとする
ウペッカーは七番目 サマーディは六番目
ウペッカーっていうのは
あの 日本訳できない言葉でしょうし
あの シャーと書いてますけどもね
どっちともシャーですね
ウペッカーっていうのは
このやっぱり今までのこの六つの条件を同じレベルに持ってくる
一つ一つに別に取り憑かれるんじゃなくて
修行中ではサティに頑張るは
それからタプオシーに頑張るは色々あるんですね
精進するはまたそういういろんなこと
それで全部上手にできたところで
この七つのある一定の状態でまとめてみる
もう一応部品が揃っただけで品物ができたわけじゃなくて
ちゃんとそれは動くか動かないかとか
色々調整しなくちゃいけないんですね
一つ一つの 例えば何か組み立てだと部品を買ってきて
そこで組み立てて はい
OK 終わったっていうことではなくて
そのその部品が自分自分の働きをちゃんとして
お互いにまとめて綺麗に行動するかしないかっていうことは
例えばおもちゃの部品を持ってきて組み立てたとしても同じことなんですね
組み立てたところでちゃんと上手く動くかどうかっていう
この最後の調整しなくちゃいけないんですね
この最後の調整が調整なんですね
ウペッカーっていうのは
その人は喜びについて別に気にしない
喜びの働きはこれぐらいだから
それは OK だと 働き過ぎだったらそれちょっと抑えましょうと
あの強安ですか この落ち着いてる状態はあまり落ち着いちゃうとこれダメだと
ほどほどで落ち着いた方がいいとかね
そういう風にこの最後に全部調整するんですね
その調整によって悟りなんです
で その時は見られるものは別な時は説明します
あの今はちょっと置いておきます
で 何を見ているかというと
こうずっと膨らみ縮みかと
例えばサティを始めるのは
ここではね 膨らみ縮み見ることなんですけど
じゃあウペッカーの場合も膨らみ縮みかと
そういうことはまあ あとの話に
その時生きていらればの話なんですけど
アビダンマの最後の本に出てくるんです
で とにかくこの分を今日終わりにしなくちゃいけないんです
ですから このマッガンガに説明
道しに入ります 書いてる三十番目
で マッガンガっていうのは
これは仏教ではお釈迦様が最初に教えたことで
この四聖諦にまとめて真理を説明するときには
時はこの道は八正道だよとおっしゃりましたから
そこも入れているんですね
で 同じことなんです で
マッガンガの場合はもうちょっと
まあ違うところもありますけど
あの すべて修行っていうのをまとめちゃうんですね
マッガンガの場合は この七覚支の場合は瞑想実践
ヴィパッサナー瞑想実践なんですね
だから仏教の比丘 仏教の信徒の
ある一部の修行なんですね
七覚支は 八正道というともっと大きいんです
仏教徒のすべての生き方
仏教の道を歩みますと思ったら
その人のすべての生き方はそこにまとめてあるんです
そちらの悟りまで全部
ですから皆様その八正道を知ってますから
別に説明する必要はないと思いますけど
まあ正見 正思惟とかね
正業 正命 正精進 正念 正定であると
そちらもちゃんと正念が入ってるんです
そこで仏教徒だからやっぱり正見が必要だよと
まあ悟っても悟らなくたっても
正しい見解を持って物事をまあ世の中のくだらない人々のような角度で見ないで
釈迦様がおっしゃっているような感じで角度で物事を見ていると正見になってますよ
で 正見完成したら悟りというんですね
悟ったということは正見を完成したということですから
正見は一番目であって
また最後でもあります
八正道の正見はアルファであって
またオメガでもあります
正見から修行始めて正見で終わっちゃうんです
というわけで 仏教に入った人が最初には正見があるんだから仏教を信じるようになっちゃうんですね
正見があるんだから悟ってるかというと
そうじゃないんです 仏教をただ理解しただけ
それで頑張るとどんどん理解して最後に理解すると
最後の理解はもう悟りの正見なんですね
ですから スタート点は正見で
それからゴール到達点も正見なんです
で 正見がある人はどうしてもシユですか
正しく考えなくちゃいけない
それで一般の人々にとっては悪い考え方をやめちゃって
考え方が大丈夫するということで
それはこの七つにはあまり入りません
だけど この七つの場合はダンマヴィッジェーですね
分別ですね 正思惟というのは
綺麗なバラの花ですよというのは正思惟じゃないんです
別に考えてないんだから
その人は何も そこを考える人がそういう綺麗か綺麗じゃないか問題
そんな問題じゃないんだけど
ここにあるのは 単なる一つの何のことのない働きですよという風に見えてきますからね
そういうのは正思惟に入っちゃう
だから正思惟とこちらの覚法覚支がまとまっています
そういう人がやっぱり喋るところに気をつける
体の行動も気をつける
戒律の入るものなんですね
ですから 一般の人 仏教に入った人は
まず戒律を守らなくちゃいけない
だらしない生き方ではなくて
すごい品格のある行動な生き方をしなくちゃいけない
ですから 言葉をちゃんとコントロールして
自分の体の行動をコントロールして
正命というのは仕事ですね
仕事にしたって金儲かるんだから何やってもいいっていうことじゃなくて
やっぱり正しいことをして
人々のために何かなることをだけして
自分がその収入で適当に生きている
たくさん儲からなくてもいいんだと
悪いことだけはやめますと
いうことで そこで欲を抑えておく
それで次にあるのは正精進ですね
同じくこちらも入ってきたんですから
その正精進する それで正精進した人が
そこからまたサティの実践を始めたところで
サマーディが生まれると
そこで一番目のサティと二番目のサマーディが入ってるんですね
ですから瞑想も入ってるんです
それで一般の仏教の人だったら
ちゃんと戒律を守って
正しく仕事をして生きていて
それで時間をとってサマーディを
サティを実践してサマーディのところと
それで人生をまとめていますからね
で 悟れるということで
ですから この八正道の道というのはものすごい大きな道なんです
きめ細かい分析して説明してるところではないんです
全部ブッダ道を八正道にまとめている
七覚支の場合は瞑想し
実践する人の悟れるその一部を説明しているんです
七覚支七覚支は八正道じゃないんだけど
八正道の中に七覚支が入っている
本当は八正道の中には全てが入っている
なのに三十七菩提分枝の中に八正道も入れ込んじゃっている
そういう入れ込みがお釈迦様ではないんです
やはりそのつどそのつど説くわけなんです
一応 そこでこのアビダンマではどんな心所かという場合は
あの四つの思念処ですか
思念処はただ正念一つですよと
あの念というあの心所がありますね
あの五十一 何でしたっけ
専心処の中に あのどんな
あの平等な心所が十九あるんですよ
その十九の中に入ってるんですね
ですから このサンマッパダーナ
この四つの精進が書いてましたけど
それはこの八正道のサンマーワーヤーマと四精進また同じものだと
あの心所の中でウィリアという心所が出てくるわけですね
精進という心所がそれに入っちゃうんですね
一つですね そこでこの三十二の偈文の中で何言ってるかというと
この三十七菩提分枝は全部心所として見ると七つですよ
うーん まあそちらそのチャートないでしょう
チャート私は別にそんな
そういう面倒くさいことをやりたくないんです
そんな歳じゃないんです
二 三分あれば書けますけど
あっ ありました うん ないかな
一応あの どなたかね あの
自分の勉強には必ずなります
すごい勉強になります
私が作ったらもうほんの二
三分あれば書けますけど
そうすると ですから三十七を書いて
どんなどんな心所かと
心所もこの二十五の専心処でしょ
その二十五の専心処の中に入ってるんだから
一応宿題として書いてみたら
まあ答えはこっち書いてますけどね
ヴィヴァルチャンダ ウペッカー
サッダ パッサッディ ピーティ
サッマーディッティ サッマーサンカッパ
それからワーヤーモー
ヴィラティッター ヴィラティッターっていうのは正語
正業 正命です 十四であり
区別としては三十七 その中
うん すみません それで七つとなると
じゃあ一応まあそこら辺で終わりにということにして
あの次回はサッバサンガーという
あの 違うまとめですね
（聞き取り不能） ん？ （聞き取り不能） それでいい？早く終われば
まあ続けることにしたっても
ほんのちょっと休憩を取ってください
（聞き取り不能）ということで
一応ここで一切っていうのは人のことで
生命のことで あるいは人やら生命やらいたっても認識する働きが生命ですからね
例えば机は生命じゃないし
机が何も認識するわけじゃないし
で 私たちは生命ですから
そこで生命には一切ということです
そこで一番最初に生命って何ですかというと
つつの部分に分けるんですね
生命というのはつつの働き
まとめたところで生命と言うんです
それはカンダですか 仏教で一般的には五蘊
ですね  それも皆様知っている
รูป・เวทนา・サニャ・サンカーラ・ヴィンニャーナ
色蘊 受蘊 想蘊 行蘊 また識蘊
で 人の体 動物の体 誰の体でもあろうが
生命 輪廻の中に生きている生きとし生けるもの
すべての人が生命という場合は
この五蘊でできているんですね
一部の生命には色がない
それは梵天だけ 無色界の梵天だけ体がない
それ以外はどんな生命にもこの五つがあるんです
รูป 色蘊があるんです
色蘊というのは物質でできている形
体という機械 それは物質によって変わります
鉄でできているかもしれませんし
他のものできているかもしれません
見えないものできているかもしれませんね
空気でできているかもしれません
それを我々が知っていることじゃなくて
とにかく何でできているのか
やっぱり物質的な体が必ずあります
だから生命には必ず DNA でできてなくてはいけないと
神様でできてなくてはいけないというのは
我々人間だけの考え方です
でもこの地球でどうでも今の生命生まれる前に DNA の生命違いましたからね
生命というのは何か前は違う形でね
サンスウは 吸わない 取らない
生命 今もいますけどね
海の中に大量に 鉄がそちらで出てくるみたいし
そこで今もやっぱりずっと自分でもサンスウ出してるんですね
それで地球のかなりの量
それも生命は生命ですけどね
大きな石ですけど 巨大な石ばっかしで
でも生命なんです で まあそんなことでもありますからね
ですからこの生命体は体がある
ある必要はあるんだと
物質的な体がね だからこいつは修行者のことを言ってるんだから
我々人間の体のことは色蘊
ルーパカンダ ヴェーダナーというのはこの体自体が感じちゃうんですね
外の世界 自分がいること
触れたものを感じるし
見たものは感じるし 自分に体があることを感じるし
だからそのセンシティビリティというね
感受性自体がヴェーダナーと言うんですね
それは心の働きなんですね
物質の働きじゃないんです
物質では感じることができないんです
体という物体に心がないと感じません
何も  2番目は 3番目はサンニャカンダですね
まあサンニャーというのはすごい説明難しいことで
まあ我々の認識やら知識やらね
まあ概念や世界やらね
そういうすべてサンニャーなんですね
区別判断することやらね
それはサンニャーという働きで
それをどんな生命にもありますね
例えば外の世界を感じるんだけど
それで終わってしまえば
もう生きていられなくなっちゃうんです
感じたものはいいものか悪いものか
まあ比べ決めなくちゃいけないし
まあ人間の場合はとにかく外にあるものは何でも食べ物ということにならないでしょうに
食べ物そうでないものとかね
でちゃんと分別しなくちゃいけない
サンニャーの方が弱くなったらね
ボケたりして それで手に入るものは何でも食べるでしょうし
ですから サンニャーっていうのはそういうことでもう必要なもので
どんな生命にもあります
アメーバから我々知ってるゾウさんまで
どんな生命にもちゃんとサンニャーっていうのはあるんですね
我々人間にとっては勉強するものは全部サンニャーなんですね
それから頭で考えて考えて理解したりする
この頭の思索も全部サンニャーっていう働きですね
で 次にあるのはサンカーラ
サンカーラっていうのは行ですね
サンカーラっていうのは
やっぱりこうやっていろんなもう
外の世界を感じたりして
それから判断したりしちゃうと
次に何かしなくちゃいけない状態になるんですね
だから何かしなくちゃいけないんだから感じたりする
感じたものから また何かしなくちゃいけないっていう
この働かなくちゃいけないという感覚
感じがいつでもあるんです
生きていなくちゃいけないという
何かしなくちゃいけない
もう何もしなくてもいいという瞬間も生まれません
いつでも何かしていることになっちゃうんです
寝てもそれは何かしていることで
休もうと思ったら それは何かしていることで
仕事をすると それはまた何かしていることで
何かしているということからは絶対死ぬまで離れません
それ行なんです そういうのは瞑想をもって
このエネルギーというのは巨大なエネルギーというのはもう区別
分別能力で そういうのはちゃんと明確に見えてきます
で 最後はヴィンヤーナ
ヴィンヤーナっていうのは
まず体 物質だ 体は物質だと言ったでしょう？だから体はなぜ生命かというと
ヴィンヤーナで生命なんですね
色があるんだから生命なんです
でも色が心が独りでいるわけじゃないんです
やっぱり機械が必要なんです
だから物質って物体として体がわかりますから
その体生かしているあの命そのものが色なんですね
命というものである命があるんだから感じたりする
考えたりする 何かしなくちゃということもやったりする
それは行蘊なんですね
ですから その分け方は随分不思議で
この最初は物質は分かりやすいんだからね
物質的な体から そこから始めて我々生きているものがやっている行動を説明して
サンニャーやらヴェーダナー一番分かりやすくて
ヴェーダナーとサンニャーとサンカーラ説明して
その働きは誰がやってるかというと
色がやってるんだと 色はなかなか人間には区別できない
私に心があるということは残念ながら
なぜかというと 心で知るんだから
心で心を知るということはちょっとややこしいんですね
包丁がものを切るんであって
包丁が自分を切るということはもうありえないとヨーロッパでも偉そうなことを言ってるんですからね
ですから この色ということはちょっと把握しにくい
ですから 体物体かといえば
科学的には正真正銘の物体なんですけど
あれ？ちょっと違うところがあるんで
その違うところが心ですね
その違うところの中でも明確に分離できるものがありますね
感じることが別に分離できる
考えたりすることはちゃんと別に分離することはできる
それからやりたいとか思っている
すごいエネルギーがきちんと分離できる
そこはその三つのそいたら何もわからない
何かエネルギーの働きが残っちゃうし
それはヴィンヤーナですね
だからその五蘊の順番さえ理解できるような順番でできているんです
まあ何のことなく簡単に
まあただ 5つに分けたということでもないんです
分けて順番考えた時には
一番理解しやすい色から始めて
理解しにくいヴィンヤーナで終わっちゃうんです
ヴィンヤーナ自体がこの瞑想の世界で
ヨーガの世界で この魂やと言っているのは
その概念もない 感じることもない
自他も差もない ただその感覚が我だよ
真我だよと 体がこの純粋ヴィンヤーナのことを言っているんですね
ヴィンヤーナには私がいるんだということも概念入ってるんだから
それでサンニャーですね
それは真我ではないんだと
とりあえず瞑想をもって
そういうありとあらゆる概念やらね
もう全部瞑想訓練だからね
全部排除しちゃうんですね
そこで体に純粋にヴィンヤーナ
純粋には働きませんだけど
もう体はもう心身分析してないんだからね
心身はありますけど やっぱりとにかくヴィタッカ
ビチャーラが消える 尋思
考えることは消える 考えることを消えたところで
それはまあ考えてないんだから
自他も考えてないんだから
まあそれは真我だよと言うんですね
それを誤解だよと言うために
それは色だよと 色自体も変化していく流れですよということを言っている
当たり前でしょうではないか
あんた一貫戦場に入ったら影響的に戦場かというとそうじゃないでしょう
インドで一人のそんな人いなかったんだから
そういう真我を体験した人はそれっきりで目が覚めないはずなんです
だから心が変化するんだから
また概念が生まれちゃうんですね
ですから当たり前に変化するでしょうということでね
ということで 仏教でそういうことを言っているんです
で 次に同じことをウパーダーナカンダと言うんですね
で なんで同じ五蘊が五取蘊と言うんですかと
だから人々が何に執着しているんですか？何に囚われているんですかと
我々の解脱を妨げているのは悪魔ですかと
神様ですかと という問題あるでしょうね
一体私の問題は何でしょうかと
私が苦しんでいるのは何でしょうかと
それ簡単に答えなんです
あなたはこの五蘊に囚われているんだと
体に 何もないんだよ 神様でも
例えば神様を導入すれば
その宗教が屁理屈になるでしょ？無慈悲になるでしょうに
絶対的な慈悲である全知全能である神に創造されたと
創造された被創造者の中で幸福な人を見て不幸
いるんだけど あれなんですかと
というと答えがないでしょ
なんである人に子供がいて
ある人に子供がないかと
なんである人は二十歳になる前に白血病で死んじゃうし
なんである人は面倒見てくれる人もいないのに百十歳まで生きているんだとか
なんである人は風邪引いただけでも死んじゃいます
なんである人は家もないのに
ホームレスなのに 寒さでも雨の中でも何のことなくもう苦しみながら寝ている
早く死んだ方がその人にとっては楽なんですけど
食べ物もないんだから
いるところもないんだから
でもなんでとかね それには神様には説明ないんですね
だからそれを神様の計画で言ったら
なんで人をある人が選んで不幸にさせ
不幸にするんですか？と言ったらこう言うんですね
それはその人のことを見て
あんた方はしっかりしなさいということやと
それで我々のために被害者になっている人にとって何か得がありますかと
何の得がないんですね
ということで 得があると言ったならば
世の中で不幸な人々が神様を信じても信じなくても
神様の仕事をやってるんだから
一番最高の位に カトリック教で言えば仙人ですか？聖人ですか？聖人の位になるはずなんですね
そうじゃないでしょ だからもう矛盾だらけになっちゃうんですね
そんな妄想して なんか喋ろうと思った
思っちゃうと ですから本当はそんなことじゃなくて
私はなぜ苦しみか 何に囚われているか
私の問題何ですかと聞くと
あなたはあなたの体に囚われているんだと
あなたの考え方に囚われているんだと
あなた体で感じるこの感覚に囚われてるんだと
具体的にそうでしょうに
なんで美味しいものを食べたいかと
なんで映画見たい あれやりたいかと
何でおしゃれしたくなるんだとかね
それは体で感じる感覚に囚われてるからでしょうに
なんで仏教を理解しなくて
今まで作ってる固定概念に囚われてるんだからでしょうに
だから我々の足かせになっているのは
やはり我々の思考 我々の考え
勉強したもの 我々の体の感覚
体自体 物体そのもの それから心という 5つですね
だから同じ五蘊 五取蘊と言うんです
それですっごい仏教で全部答えてるんです
だから神様非難することもない
否定することもない もう関係ないことで
具体的に見れば 客観的に見れば
科学的に見れば 私はこの体に囚われているんだと
私の問題はここにあるんだと
例えば天国に行きたいと泣き叫ぶ人が
なんでそういう風に泣き叫ぶんですかね
この体に囚われてるからでしょ
天国に行きたと思うないんだから
なんだかんだこの体から生まれたもの
それものだよと それから認識の世界説明しようと
仏教は認識の問題 そこで十二処出てくるんですね
十二処っていうのは それまたすごい
ものすごいまとめている素晴らしい分析だと私は思います
この体と この五蘊でできている体と
外の客体の世界と どこでつなげているかと
だからつなげてる場所は十二処ですね
十一か所ですからつなげてないのと
ですからどこかというと
チャックソータ・ガーナ・ジフア・カヤ・マナでしょ
眼耳鼻舌身意でしょ それは体の窓口六つですね
その窓口があって そこから外の世界は全部私知ってるわけじゃなくて
その窓口の六つでつなげているんですね
目には見える形でつながっている
耳には音でつなげている
だからこの六つの窓口と六つのチャンネルを明確にすると
なんだ私たち世の中知っていたわけじゃないということがわかるんです
ただ一部の情報を取ってるだけと
それは人間にとっては全てだと
どんな生命体にとってもそれだけ全てだと
どんな生命もこの十二の窓口でつなげているんです
そこで眼耳鼻舌身意と色声香味触法と
この十二っていうのはもう大変な
もうすごい分析なんです
これでもって もう全ての哲学やらもう存在の問題やら
仏教ではこれは答えだよと言ってることなんです
そのやたらにけなしてはいけませんし
般若心経みたいに全部壊してやるぞ
そんなことはないんだと
であれ だから別に仏教でもそんなことないと言っています
じゃあ仏教はそう言うために分析するんです
じゃあチャックは魂かと
根は永遠のものかと 無常だよと言うために分析しているんだから
般若心経書いた人々はものすごい大勘違いなんですね
邪教の人々より勘違いしてるんです
だからなんでこの十二処をおっしゃったかというと
十二処が無常だよと言うために明確にこの錯誤を隠して分析してもらってるんです
無常やと無我やと空やと言うために
だから色は空だよと だから空は色だよというのは
まあもう呆れちゃう この頭の悪さに
それより自分こそ頭がイカれてるからが面白い
これほど冗談じゃないんです
私はそういう経典なんか読むとすごい刺激なんです
で それでダートということがあります
十八回と このダートっていうのは
またこの また存在の説明なんですね
私には十六の窓口がある
私ではなくて 十六の窓口で働いて私ができているし
それでその十六 十六じゃない
六の窓口で私ができているし
その六の窓口に六つの働きが触れているし
そこで私がいるという認識が生まれるんですね
ですから 私がいるという認識も六なんですね
だから目から私がいるという認識が生まれると
見るんだから 耳からその認識が生まれるんだから
知識が生まれるんだから
それまた私がいるということになっちゃうんだから
それで十八ができますけど
ちょっと言葉のちょっとした問題があるんですね
そこで十八はこういうこと
チャック 目 それから色
目に見える形 それから眼識
チャックヴィンヤーナ
目と識が触れたら認識が生まれるんですね
その三つ 目と色と触れたところで生まれる認識と
耳と音と両方触れたところで生まれる知識と
そこで十八は簡単にわかりますね
で ここで問題は六番目なんですね
六番が意だから 心に何が触れるかと
目に触れるものはもう知ってますけどね
耳に触れるものは知ってますけどね
心に何が触れるかっていうことで
施設際部やっぱり実際する方が触れるんだと
と言ったんだけど こちらではそれはそうではなく
その代わりにマノーダートゥ
意塊があって それでマノーヴィンニャーナダートゥというのは意識ですね
それからダンマダートゥと
ダンマダートゥは法塊になりますけど
それは何のことなく心に心の対象ということで
だから心の対象の場合は
両者仏教でいうのは心があるものもないものも認識するんだと
施設際部みたいにあるものしか認識しませんよと言ってないんです
それで彼らには過去もあるんだと
今すでに 将来も今すでにあるんだと言わざるを得なくなったんですね
テーラワーダでは簡単に解決するんです
簡単に テーラワーダの場合には
心にはあるものもないものも
別に心を認識するために別にものがなくてもいいんだと
だから将来はないのに
我々はいろんな将来のことを考えてるでしょ？でもほとんどそういう風にならないでしょうに
そういう風にはならないんですけど
いちいち将来のことを考えちゃう
それから幻覚とかね いろんなこの今漫画の世界でいろんな怪獣描いたり
いろんなモンスターたちを描いたりする
それはどこにも存在しないものなんですけど
やっぱり意ではそういうことも創造することが可能ということ
それで お釈迦様がおっしゃった真理あります
四聖諦があって それでこの章は終わります
四聖諦の中でも全部入ります
だから一切の分析ですね
だから苦というのは存在のことですね
苦 苦聖諦 集というのは渇愛のなぜ苦しみが世の中存在が現れるかという
それは心にある煩悩で渇愛であるんだから現れるんだと
因果法則なんですね そこですべてのことを説明してるんです
ここで反対に渇愛が この因果法則が消えちゃったら
ものの現れはないんだ
その体験するためには心の問題ですから
八正道があるんだということで
四聖諦という それすべてのお釈迦様の教え
四聖諦なんです だから四聖諦というのは
この中ですべてまた説明してるんです
終わりです 次はこの八正道に入ります
[背景音]